let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
it is
wednesday
afternoon
three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern
and this week
alls we can hear is afghanistan
afghanistan
afghanistan
so i would imagine today
we are going to talk a little bit about
afghanistan
now we'll probably talk a little bit
about the current president
and the former guy of course because
they both had a little bit to do with
afghanistan there's a few other
presidents that also had some [ __ ] to do
with afghanistan
so i'm sure today
because afghanistan afghanistan
afghanistan afghanistan
we will talk
on afghanistan now the other thing i
want to touch on today is uh jeffrey
tubin that jagoff
he wrote an article about how
trump should or should not be prosecuted
now last week if you tuned in to the
special guest episode with jimmy kennedy
the executive producer of the noel
castler podcast we actually talked about
trump being prosecuted trump going to
prison would he wouldn't he a lot so me
and jimmy hashed a little bit of that
out last week
but
this week we have this
tubin
giving his opinion on whether trump
should or should not be prosecuted so
we're going to talk about that a little
bit the other thing i want to talk about
today
is uh
marjorie three toes gang green
being banned from twitter
and why the hell
why the hell hasn't twitter banned her
permanently uh you know
because she's the marge
hashtag ban marge
so if you're out there and you're on
that hashtag on twitter uh you know what
i'm talking about
uh the old old three toes
so we have a lot of a lot of things to
talk about today and the reason why is
because there's a lot to unpack
with this afghanistan war exit because
uh some people see it as a debacle some
people are saying yes this is a good
thing some people say no this is a bad
thing
on and on and on and on there's all
kinds of opinions on this
and have you noticed that uh all these
vaccine experts vaccine twitter experts
you know the ones that
think it's you know
whatever they think it is and they're
not going to get it mostly the
anti-baxters
they all of a sudden they've all of a
sudden become military strategist that's
incredible whoa who'd have thought that
just poof all of a sudden
they know a lot about military strategy
you know just like they know a lot about
a deadly pathogen or lack thereof
rather they believe it or not that kind
of funny kind of funny how that works
so
let's get to the band marge thing and
i'm gonna get that out of the way
and it's not gonna take long to talk
about this knuckle this knuckle dragger
this this
ninja poop nazi neanderthal
what a [ __ ] idiot of course she's
posting misinformation
on any subject she possibly can i mean
that's what these people are doing
that's the whole strategy here
is to
to convince these people as as much
disinformation as they possibly can to
have these people so deluded that
they'll believe [ __ ] like donald trump
is the answer to their prayers
so of course they're going to pedal and
delusion rather it's
about this afghanistan war
if it's about the vaccine if it's about
the virus of course they're going to
peddle misinformation
that's that's the entire purpose is to
sell the lie sell the lies sell the lies
sell lie because if you can sell these
people enough lies you can sell them
anything you want
and anything you want can be the truth
that they want that's how it's gonna
work
so marjorie taylor green
posting misinformation on on on
twitter or anywhere else
is par for the course same way with like
uh lauren bobert or
mo brooks or
you know any of these knuckle dragon
idiots
but i'll tell you
i was talking to some people over the
weekend and
i kind of think and i think i've brought
this up on the podcast before because i
i believe this i think the what we have
with them marjorie taylor green the
lauren lauren boberts
jim jordan matt getz some of these
[ __ ] just complete boneheads tommy
tuberville
josh holly all these [ __ ] idiots
the reason why we had this
is because john mccain picked sarah
palin
and sarah palin was sarah palin before
it was cool
now we have dozens
dozens of these [ __ ] running
around in congress with elected office
now if you remember sarah palin was the
you remember you remember her she was
the and i guess maybe she's gonna run
for senate i doubt it you know it's just
just to get her to trend on on twitter
so she can you know peddle something
else
but uh sarah palin was the governor of
alaska when john mccain picked her to be
the vp
now
for all intents and purposes sarah palin
became a cartoon character of herself
a complete cartoon character of herself
because she came on the national stage
and she had to prove to everybody that i
don't know she was an idiot or something
you remember the katie kirk interview
when she asked her what do you read she
said everything yeah i read everything
you name it i read it
and before 8 o'clock between 6 30 and 8
o'clock i read the entire national news
and and every newspaper and every
magazine i'm a speed reader or something
i who the [ __ ] can tell with these
people you remember the moment oh it's a
gotcha moment she didn't get her
anything
sarah palin got
herself but it was marketable that was
marketable
because what they found out in that
process is us being stupid the
politicians
like sarah palin us being stupid is
marketable the reason why is because
liberals
and the media calls us dumb and stupid
and that way we can campaign off of it
because our enemy is calling us the
enemy so now we can campaign off of it
so now we got dozens of these
[ __ ] and lauren bobert even
does the bippity bop thing she's got the
glasses on she does the hair like sarah
palin
i mean she's like sarah palin light
you know
maybe maybe sarah palin and sarah palin
light
and lauren bogart's the diesel i don't
know
but that's why we're in a situation that
we're in with marjorie taylor green or
lauren bobert and really these two
[ __ ] morons should be kicked off
twitter in the first place now
you know it's it's very unclear what the
hell they would do with their official
account but they they took
president trump's official account down
when he was the president
they cut that son of a [ __ ] off
cut him off
so they can do the same thing with
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
whoever
ted cruz is another one
rand paul
that that [ __ ] misinformation
profiteer he's profiting
he's profiting off his misinformation
you got desantis down in florida talking
about trying to hawk regeneron have you
heard this
or generon i guess regeneron the the the
treatment is a thousand to fifteen
hundred hours or something as if any
normal person can just oh you know i
test positive for cobit so i'll spend
1500 hours to get the regeneron
he's hawking regeneron as opposed to you
know
free mitigate practically free
mitigation tactics
masking vaccines
and he's hawking regeneron but you know
because they give to his campaign and he
might own stocks or who knows that's a
legend but i don't give a [ __ ]
they're misinformation profiteers
they're profiting off misinformation and
and
when when they sarah palin it they get
the gotcha moment oh they got you they
realized that with these boneheads out
there these these trumplites these trump
bumpers these maga q anon evangelical
spread necks
that it's profitable
because if there's a gotcha moment then
we can fundraise off of it and boy
there's nothing better than fundraising
when you're a member of congress because
it's not about policy
it's about filling that old bank account
don't you know that that's a whole
[ __ ] point to fill to fill the
campaign coffers that way you can
launder it through the campaign and
stick it in your pocket ask donald trump
ask him
the launderer in chief right
now that i've gotten to and and and one
last thing before i get to
trump
and criminal prosecution and jeffrey
toobin dumbass
let me just say
out there to
twitter do we want or ban of course we
do
of course we do you don't want this
misinformation running around convincing
people of dumb stupid [ __ ] but at the
same time are we really gonna take a
good form of entertainment away with
lauren povert and marjorie taylor green
ban those [ __ ] bantam take them
off the platform jack
jack
ban them
so let's get to trump and criminal
prosecution because we we just called
him the launderer in chief
because that's what he
it's what he is the laundering chief and
we're going to talk about trump a couple
times a day of course
because this [ __ ] [ __ ] just can't
stop but sticking his whiny little [ __ ]
head in places that it doesn't need to
be
retire already with some dignity oh
that's right
you have none
so jeffrey tubin if you guys don't
remember this is the guy that caught got
caught wanking it on a zoom call right
you remember this he worked for the new
yorker he was on a a phone meeting a
zoom phone meeting they went on break
while they were on break he decided to
wax the old carrot
and he didn't realize his camera was
still on
an embarrassing moment
he was a cnn contributor they suspended
him the new yorker fired his ass
for waxing his carrot now i don't think
that
you know accidentally waxing your carrot
on a zoom call disqualifies you from
knowing something or not knowing
something
but what i do think what i do think is
when jeffrey toobin
decides to get when they just when cnn
decides to unsuspend him because he's a
white dude because let's face it if he's
a black dude or a woman he wouldn't see
the light of day
not the [ __ ] light of day
come on
no one would forgive that
no one would shut up about it
and i'm not gonna shut up about it
he can go [ __ ] himself literally i mean
he likes to do it i hear so
but jeffrey toobin writes an article
he writes an article
about trump being prosecuted or not
being prosecuted and his advice
his advice and he's begging the
department of justice not to do it
not to prosecute that's his stance do
not prosecute trump there's not enough
evidence number one how in the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] does jeffrey tuban know
if there's enough evidence to prosecute
trump yet or not for anything
for anything there's plenty
investigations that are very close to
him and his allies
that give that give way
to possibly
possibly him committing federal crimes
state crimes tax crimes election crimes
who knows what crimes
we have several investigations that are
tied close to trump
i mean just to name a few number one of
them is his his company
his company his own personal company
that he owns and he runs the trump
organization is indicted
in the state of new york under the
manhattan d.a who has his tax returns
they have them congress is trying to get
them but they have them that grand jury
has those [ __ ]
they indicted the trump organization and
alan weisselberg
for crimes
tech schemes
also close to trump
and and the trump campaign of 2016 or
thereafter
is a federal indictment on tom barrick
for you know foreign influence
into the uae
of course
it seems kind of convenient that alan
weisselberg and tom barrack
are under two separate indictments
that really kind of
man it looks like they tied together
because what tom barrack and alan
weisselberg have in common allegedly is
they were both working on the inaugural
campaign
and there's a lot of questions from the
inaugural campaign are they excuse me
the inaugural committee
and the money that went into the
inaugural committee of 2016 when donald
trump
became president and me and jimmy talked
about this last week
me and jimmy surmised that that no
casler no casler
was it both of obama's inaugurations
big hitters
i mean big celebrities a lot of [ __ ]
money
a ton of money
well trump raised almost three or four
times as much as obama for his inaugural
committee
and trump had
d list acts
[Music]
and he's he spent
four times as much i thought he was a
good deal maker i thought he was a good
business person what's this about
because really folks god damn the
question isn't where the money go
of course of course everyone could come
manage to come up with where the money
went
i mean
probably part of it went up donald trump
junior's nose and part of it went to
jared kushner to bail him out of some of
his bad property deals
and ivanka
you know
and then of course some of it lying
donald trump's pockets it's not
confusing no one's [ __ ] confused
about that
the question is the question is can they
prove that and the other question is
where the [ __ ] did this money come from
where did all this money come from
where did it come from did it come from
small donations
or did it come from donating overseas
where it's possible
that someone would broker a deal with
maybe like i don't know the uae
something like that the saudis maybe i
don't know
by then someone by the name of tom
barrack maybe i don't know
and maybe just maybe part of the deal
was
to get things you know maybe like a
presidential visit to be the first
presidential visit of that president's
tenure
i don't know
maybe
maybe
i mean
you know if you can
do dot to dot
it's the criminal dot to dot right
so
jeffrey toobin surmises that trump
should not be prosecuted not because
well he does say that there's not enough
evidence in the public forum which that
has nothing to do with prosecution
number one
anybody who's anybody who knows who's
smart enough to know just because
there's public information in the public
forum doesn't mean that that it triggers
an indictment or doesn't trigger an
indictment because sometimes the public
knows just as much as prosecutors or are
a hell of a lot less and generally
speaking
they know a hell of a lot less and
that's the rule not the exception
so for jeffrey toobin to assume that
there's not enough evidence because
there's not enough evidence in the
public forum to prosecute him whether
it's in the federal court or state court
like georgia or new york
that does not mean
that does not mean that the feds nor the
manhattan d.a have enough evidence
to indict him
so his point in the article is to say
we should make this a political argument
it should be a political trial we done
had the political trial
we done had it
he was impeached twice
twice for cheating by the way cheating
an election
that's what he was impeached for twice
now he wasn't convicted because you have
a bunch of [ __ ] capitulators
but he was impeached twice for cheating
in an election once because he was
trying to trade deals
with ukraine to give the government
money that we were supposed to give him
as aid military to fight against our
enemy russia
he was gonna quit pro quo that so that
way you know the ukrainians would bang
up joe biden because he was terrified
absolutely [ __ ] terrified of joe
biden
because they knew joe biden would wax
his ass and he did
a broken clock is right twice a day and
trump was right when he knew that joe
biden would kick his ass
in an election because he did
took him behind the woodshed and spanked
his hind ass
it's a big hind ass but spanked it
by 8 million votes
that's the first time he tried to cheat
and got impeached for it
trying to cheat an election trying to
trying to jim up evidence
on his opponent
so that way if he had to run against old
uncle joe he could beat him because he
knew he wouldn't otherwise
then then he gets impeached for january
6
because he tries to commit a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
and we're finding out more more that
there was a hell of a lot more to the
kangaroo coup which we knew that
everyone knew there was more to the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
it was just a matter of time gathering
up the evidence and getting people in in
in front of these [ __ ] committees
the select committee
and even the the senate judiciary
committee and the doj ig
to figure out what the hell was actually
going on and who was involved in trying
to have a soft coup before january 6
because that's what they were trying to
do with jeffrey clark's letters
and jeffrey rosen the acting attorney
general doesn't go to the ig and to the
judiciary committee in the senate
just over one goddamn letter
for eight [ __ ] hours eight hours he
testifies over one letter from jeffrey
clark i don't think so
i don't think so give me a [ __ ] break
so there's the second time
that trump was impeached the second
political trial as jeffrey toobin wants
the political solution
that's the second one there wasn't a
political solution because the
republican party are a bunch of
capitulating cowards
they're [ __ ] cowards
they would much rather much rather
placate to fascism and their and their
trump media fans
that's right
it's all for the fans all of it
every time they say something every time
they do something it ain't got nothing
to do with the truth
it ain't got nothing to a policy it
ain't got nothing to do with having a
government it ain't got nothing to do
with the republic
it ain't got nothing to do with
democracy
it is 100 percent to please the fan base
they learned that from old [ __ ]
grandpa poopy pants the cheeto dust
mobster
whatever they want you to say you just
say it
and we've had two political trials over
this
two of them
and now we're gonna have
not just the select committee for
january six
as a political and congressional
investigation
into what happened and who's what and
who's where with the department of
justice and the executive branch we also
are going to have investigations in the
senate
in the senate judiciary committee
jeffrey rosen the acting the former
acting attorney general under trump in
december and january when they were
trying to
when they were trying to attempt the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
has already went and testified and made
sure that there's an investigation in
that senate judiciary committee
so what the [ __ ] is jeffrey tubin
talking about
that there's not enough evidence in the
public forum
number one there is enough evidence in
the public forum to assume that donald
trump could possibly be indicted
on several different fronts not just the
inaugural committee but also january 6
and possibly
and possibly the trump organization if
they were committing tax fraud on a
state level
and the manhattan d.a is able to prove
it for the trump organization don't you
think they'll give a federal referral to
the southern district of new york don't
you think
come on
jeffrey tubin
you jagoff
so we got jeffrey tubing loving trump
because you know
these journalists got their [ __ ]
heads up their asses again
they're back in a world
where they must they must they must get
ratings
and maybe loving trump will give him
ratings again i don't know
what the [ __ ] he's thinking
if you use your brain for a half a
second you realize that because his
argument is is that if we prosecute this
president we'll have to prosecute all of
them that's b that's the base of his
argument which is all [ __ ]
i mean yeah to some level if you
prosecute one president you may have to
prosecute them all but not if that
[ __ ] idiot's doing [ __ ] criming
outside the presidency have you ever
considered that jeffrey tubin
that we shouldn't make every [ __ ]
president immune from any kind of law
it's not like trump has stopped criming
let's say the guy crimed up until
january 20th of 2021 do you think he
just stopped
when he got on the plane
and they're like sir you're not the
president anymore uncle joe's the
president now do you think he just
stopped crying he was like all right
okay well let's stop all the money
laundering situations let's do all let's
stop all of that because you know i
don't want to go i don't want to crime
anymore i'm going to go straight no
no they kept it going what do you think
the my pillow guy is
[ __ ] we can't even hardly get into that
because we have so much goddamn news on
afghanistan and jeffrey toobin
jagging off the trump
maybe on a zoom call i don't know
but here we are
here we are
with
journalists assuming
in their articles that trump can't be
prosecuted because he used to be the
president because it says it says no
one's above above the law no one
no one and we did this stupid [ __ ] when
ford pardoned nixon
this this is the this is the
the the thing that that that did
is let these [ __ ] say oh you
can't prosecute a president
what happens if you prosecute this
president you might have to prosecute
all of them
well prosecute them if they're doing
crimes you dumb [ __ ]
that's what we should do that's what
other countries do
is prosecute them and imprison them when
they're committing crime
just a thought
speaking of mike lindell
did you guys see that [ __ ]
did you guys see the the ending
of the symposium
that went over like a wet fart and a
white thong
what the [ __ ]
supposed to [ __ ] resign the friday
august the 13th
trump was gonna ascend to the presidency
and then he's on sean hannity's show
last night
[ __ ] out word salad [ __ ] his diaper
all over tv over afghanistan what the
[ __ ] was that what was he talking about
something about kim jong-un and all
kinds of [ __ ]
he just he couldn't even put a thought
together
he's trying to talk about afghanistan
but he
he really he remembered he remembered
the president's name of afghanistan of
course
you know the guy that took off with 170
million dollars worth of cash the other
day
leaves afghanistan with 170 million
dollars worth of cash i wonder how much
of that cash is supposed to end up in a
trump tower somewhere you ever wonder
that have you guys wondered then you're
like 170 million dollars
damn
he picked up and moved for 170 million
bucks because the taliban's like you're
out [ __ ]
at 170 million dollars just sitting
around
i wonder i wonder how many condos and
trump towers that 170 million dollars
can afford you know trump tower and
wherever
i guess
maybe maybe maybe they'll they'll take
vacations at golf courses trump golf
courses with that 170 million dollars i
don't know
i'm just i'm just throwing around ideas
i'm not saying i know anything in
particular i'm just saying it seems kind
of suspicious you know kind of odd
i just want to know how much a condo
cost at a trump tower like how much cash
a former
uh president of afghanistan who fled his
country with 170 million dollars would
have to would have to spend to buy a
condo at a trump tower i'm just
wondering
what the price is
what the market value of condos are
right now
just surmising
oh
afghanistan afghanistan afghanistan
afghanistan afghanistan so
the last president
presidential candidate i should say the
last presidential candidate to actually
run to stay in the the war in
afghanistan
was john mccain and we talked about john
mccain just a little bit ago with sarah
palin
but that was the last presidential
candidate to actually
campaign to say no we need to stay in
afghanistan
you know to tamp down terrorism because
the war on terror isn't over and all
kinds of [ __ ]
and he lost
obama
ran to get out of afghanistan
he ran again in 2012 to get out of
afghanistan
and mitt romney ran to get out of
afghanistan
2016 there was two candidates
hillary clinton and donald trump they
both ran to get out of afghanistan
donald trump became president we all
know that
in 2006 2020 excuse me
joe biden and donald trump kind of had
the same stance get out of afghanistan
get out of afghanistan and the reason
why folks is because the american people
don't want to be in a static war in
afghanistan
and this week has made it more clear
than ever why the american people think
this is a bad idea
because it is a bad idea it has been a
bad idea for a long goddamn time
now
i don't want to forget about the
president that got us in
to afghanistan and put us there pretty
much [ __ ] permanently and we all know
who the [ __ ] that is
w
george w bush
folks we are sending soldiers
to afghanistan
young men and women american soldiers to
afghanistan
that were not alive
on 9 11 when those planes hit the towers
they weren't even alive
that's how long our [ __ ] asses have
been over there doing whatever the [ __ ]
we thought we were doing spreading
democracy
making them love freedom whatever the
[ __ ] it is we thought we were doing
being a military industrial complex is
what we were doing
and those seem to be the the people that
are the most upset about us leaving
and they seem the most upset about the
circumstances of us leaving not you know
they can't outright say
we we should stay there
because now that we see what we see it's
hard to say
that that we should stay there
but the military industrial complex is
[ __ ] pissed
regardless of the reason that they give
on television
that the media gives on television
but george w bush got us in afghanistan
we got rid of al qaeda we tamp down
taliban you remember mission
accomplished mission accomplished the
big banner you remember it everybody
remembers it and then we were gonna do
what they called nation
building and we did almost 18 years of
that [ __ ]
we should have left then
and the next thing you know
afghanistan isn't our biggest concern
anymore it's weapons of mass destruction
in iraq
and we placated that stupid [ __ ] mess
that [ __ ] lie
that was the big lie before there was a
big lie with trump
is weapons of mass destruction
and we have liz cheney this week
her thing is oh well well
we should blame it on obama we should
blame it on biting it has nothing to do
with my daddy
nothing to do with my daddy and nothing
to do with george w bush
because you know when the war started
that you can't you can't blame that
person
and then for george w bush to have the
goal to even release a statement other
than i'm really sorry america
i'm really sorry i did that thing nope
couldn't say that
why don't you stay in texas do your
little your little paintings and shut
the [ __ ] up
[Music]
we know what you did we're done dealing
with it we've been dealing with it and
the american people have been trying to
vote in presidents to get rid of this
[ __ ]
the last candidate i'll say it again the
last candidate to even run
to even run to stay in afghanistan was
mccain
in 2008
13 years ago
so by that math we're 13 years they're
too goddamn long
and joe biden has been against the
occupation the permanent occupation of
afghanistan since that time and the
reason why is because obama ran to get
us out of afghanistan and if you
remember
about which americans can't remember a
[ __ ] goddamn thing
but if americans if you can remember
back in 2009 obama came out and gave a
speech about the afghanistan war and
trying to get it out of afghanistan and
iraq and he's they we had to have a
surge to make sure that country was
secure before we pull our troops out and
of course that's what the military
industrial complex wanted they wanted
the surge because they knew what the
surge meant
the surge meant that we weren't getting
out
that's always been the game oh let's
send more to make it safer that way we
can pull out safely
as if the surge is a condom or something
i don't know
the thing that we do know is it the
surge kept us there longer
longer and longer and longer
now donald trump made a deal with the
taliban a lot of people are still
speculating what that deal actually
means and if the taliban will stay to
that deal
it seems as if today they're staying to
that deal
but we don't know how long that'll last
it's hard to trust the taliban
that's why you generally don't negotiate
with them
trump
but let me tell you something the deal
that trump made can you imagine
he's the only one that can make that
deal
he's the only one that could make that
deal if you really think about it
he's the scumbag of the scumbags of the
scumbags of course of course the left
goes of course that guy negotiates with
terrorists
and the [ __ ] ninka poops on the right
are like yeah he could he he
he really gave it to him he he really
gave it to him he kept them in their
place
you know the same [ __ ] with kim jong-un
right the same [ __ ] they said how he
capitulated to that [ __ ]
same [ __ ] nonsense
can you imagine
can you imagine for a second if barack
obama
barack hussein obama would have made
that deal with the taliban
holy actual [ __ ]
the entire [ __ ] right wing apparatus
would have [ __ ] been on fire
it would have been like nuclear media
warfare
if barack obama would have made a deal
with the taliban
can you even start
start to unpack that in your mind
for these morons
because they don't even notice that
trump did the deal with taliban
oh what what joe biden he's friends with
the taliban now huh oh you can't get our
interpreters out can you joe biden
well here's the thing folks congress
voted on a little bill not too long ago
and 16 republican congress people 16
voted against
helping getting afghans that helped us
in the 20-year war
to get them out
and since that time
passed since that time we've expedited
over two thousand well over two thousand
people to this country
our country afghans
have come to our country since that time
they act like there isn't one person
that's left afghanistan and came to this
country the media and the right wing
alike
and they [ __ ] voted against it 16 of
them and and they were the ones that
were
most vocal about oh you're just going to
leave our house you're just going to
leave our house
you're not going to help them out oh joe
biden you piece of [ __ ]
no i don't want them afghanis in our
country
we don't want brown people them brown
muslims in our country
of course they don't they're bigots
but they don't know what they believe
anymore
that's why you have these these [ __ ]
morons
attacking joe biden for the [ __ ] that
donald trump did
because they can't figure it out
now we had some very stark images
some very very very
stark images
when it comes to afghanistan the other
day
some of the starkest images and then
this is going to be the
the imprint
of this and that's probably the most
shameful thing
is the imprint of this and the images
of
hundreds and hundreds of afghan
people
on the tarmac while the carriers are
trying to get people off the tarmac and
and
get a plane they were hanging from the
the landing gear and everything
clinging to the side of the plane
horrible imagery horrible imagery but
the imagery that that no one is is
thinking of
is the hundreds of afghanis that were in
that [ __ ] carrier
being shuttled to safety
and then the imagery of the military
trying to secure the tarmac so they
could land planes and take planes off to
take people to safety
no everyone forgets about that imagery
there isn't fire fights
[Music]
though no one's tossing bombs at each
other here
the taliban for what it's worth
is actually holding up to its deal to
let us leave and it's in their best
interest to let us [ __ ] leave
and it's in their best interest to let
the people who want to leave to leave
and i've heard several interviews of
people in afghanistan on the phone being
interviewed by journalists
that are in hiding trying to make it to
the airport
and it seems to be the very first days
as the taliban got closer and closer to
the capital at kabul
that these people were terrified
but as the taliban
holds to their deal here to let these
people get out of the country the more
and more and more they're competent that
they'll be able to leave and the united
states government and the military are
trying to work these people out
now there is a [ __ ] paperwork problem
and they gotta figure that out
but we
should have left afghanistan
over 18 years ago
there wasn't any nation building that
happened
the taliban took back that country in
less than two weeks and they did it
without hardly firing a shot
this house of cards that we had control
of afghanistan because it was a house of
cards
come on
no one believes that the american
military was in charge of afghanistan
and no one believes that the afghan
government and the afghan military had a
strong hold on what they call a country
because afghanistan isn't a country
it's a it's a [ __ ] boundary of an
invisible line that someone drew
around provinces of tribes
they're not country they're a collection
and how do we expect them
to be a country how how would you expect
that
the only semblance that those people
have had
of collective of collectiveness
is the taliban and the taliban have fed
that for the last 20 years
and it seems like the taliban has
figured out where to put their thumb at
to make sure they can gain back control
fast
and it was due
corruption and bribes
you know the [ __ ] that trump really
likes that's why trump gets along with
this
taliban that's why he gets along with
him
you know the whole the whole loyalty
thing
hey he loved that oh and he was on
hannity's show last night giving you a
diarrhea word salad about it you can't
understand what the [ __ ] he's trying to
say but ultimately he's trying to say
the taliban's good because
they like to bribe they like the crime
there's people loyal to him and i like
that
i like that i like making people loyal
with with payments of money that's cool
i like that
you know the cheeto dust mobster really
comes out in him
when he's when he's working with the
taliban
befriending the taliban
joe biden
we bring joe biden into this
because you know it it really is all
blamed on joe biden anything that goes
wrong because it is on his watch he is
the president of the united states
and when he came out and gave his speech
he accepted it he expect he accepted
responsibility but there's one thing
that joe biden i think knows here
the american people are on his [ __ ]
side about leaving afghanistan
and there's another thing that joe biden
understands about politics is americans
are we have a really tough time
remembering anything
especially having a tough time
remembering any kind of uh uh
of debacle in the middle east just go
ask the kurds
just go ask the kurds if americans
remember
remember anything about debacles in the
middle east go ask them
but joe biden knows that and six months
from now
the thing that people remember about the
afghanistan war and the exit from that
war
especially at the taliban hold up to
what they say they're gonna do until we
leave because i think that's what's
going to happen a taliban is going to
hold up to pretty much they're in the
deal until we're gone and we've done
what we want to do and we're gone then
they can take control of the country now
rather they hold up there into the deal
of of being a little more humanitarian
you know a taliban light
than they were before we'll find that
out
and we'll have to deal with those
humanitarian issues on a humanitarian
level not a military level
but we're gonna find that out
but in six months from now joe biden
knows
that what people are gonna remember
about afghanistan is he got us out of
that war
and he got us out with trump's deal
which i don't think was ideal obviously
it was kind of a [ __ ] up
the deal was not
was not well thought through
and there was a lot of holes in the deal
and there was a lot of unknown
intelligence about the deal that they
were trying to make with the taliban
that the taliban was going to be able to
take over a hell of a lot faster than
anyone ever imagined
because of the deal that was being
struck because they went into these
palaces and just said hey you're taliban
now yep we sure as hell are we're with
you as long as you don't kill us we're
with you buddy we're taliban
not a shot fired
not a shot fired i wonder how much money
that the president walks away with
170 million dollars i wonder how much
these province presidents got i wonder
how much money they got and i wonder if
they get a trump tower condo somewhere
or not i don't know
maybe they get one maybe that's you know
it's the art of the deal folks
it's the shark of the deal the shard of
the deal
and they all get they all get a condo
all these taliban get a condo and trump
tower somewhere
but joe biden
comes out accepts responsibility
for whatever
the execution problems may have been
with the plan and the deal that donald
trump had made
and he accepts responsibility of course
he does because he's a [ __ ] president
he's a real [ __ ] president
he's there to make decisions for the
american people and he should stand
behind his decisions as a president
should
he shouldn't waffle
or whine like a little [ __ ]
i made a video about this can you
imagine can you imagine me making a
video i did i made a video about putting
your shoes on so let's watch that and
then we'll talk a little bit more about
joe biden on the other side have you
ever noticed that our country is safer
when the president gets up in the
morning puts their [ __ ] shoes on and
does their [ __ ] job making the tough
decisions for america good bad or
indifferent not whining like a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's how it's done you
[ __ ] snowflakes
[ __ ]
them so
any president is going to make mistakes
any of them it doesn't matter if you're
a george w bush
if you're a barack obama if you're
donald trump you're joe biden or you're
a hillary clinton a mitt romney and john
mccain
or a john kerry you're gonna make
mistakes
nothing's gonna go a hundred percent
now
it seems as if
the biggest mistake was why why did we
shut down the military airfield why
couldn't we use that airfield as a way
to evacuate people
now maybe it was because they thought
they could use
the airfield in kabul it was not going
to take that long maybe they thought
they weren't going to be able to
evacuate as many people in such a short
amount of time it's hard to know
but it does look like that was [ __ ] up
and it looks like that joe biden has
taken responsibility for that single
thing that that
the imagery of those people hanging on
the side of the planes and not only that
not only that he's provided the
resources and the military to get that
fixed
the other thing was was their execution
of the communication of those problems
to the media because you know if the
media doesn't have an answer right away
they freaked the [ __ ] out
freaked the [ __ ] out
now
the one thing that's for sure is joe
biden good bad or indifferent gets up in
the morning puts his [ __ ] shoes on
and does his [ __ ] job
he's not on twitter whining like a
little [ __ ] [ __ ]
because he can't get a goddamn thing
right
because he's an inherently a scumbag
that is not the case
joe biden has a policy and he's sticking
to it now he was kind of boxed in by the
deal with trump
which there's bad parts of that deal and
some of it led to this some of it didn't
and what i mean by led to it is some of
the the debacle that happened on the
exit
but you have to actually exit
you have to exit you can't say
obama did this
wrong
he was wrong
you can't say well we're gonna surge in
this many troops and then we're gonna
leave
that's not leaving
leaving doesn't mean you're gonna surge
in troops it means you pack your [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you leave
that's what it means
now
the next thing that happens the thing
that triggers that
that's the unknown now they thought they
knew they thought they knew the taliban
would take control that's what it seems
like now
and they thought they thought it would
take a while nope
there was way more corruption than they
ever knew it was all a house of cards
the taliban has been in control for a
long time it's like they never even lost
control it was just shadow control to
make the americans feel great about
their occupation of their country you
know just laying in wait for the
americans to leave so they could take
their their quote-unquote country back
yes
yes a lot of this falls on joe biden
but what about george w bush
what about barack obama what about
donald trump
it's a 20-year war folks and we made a
shitload of mistakes and the worst
mistake we made wasn't
wasn't having planes at the ready to get
every single person out of afghanistan
at a moment's notice that wasn't the
worst mistake
it was not
that's all [ __ ]
so
i appreciate that joe biden accepts
the responsibility for the for the
downfalls of the execution of the exit
in afghanistan but i also appreciate
that the guy made the [ __ ] decision
that he didn't let
oh a little bit of heartache get in the
way of doing what you had to do and
doing what he said he would do
so let's remember that
now i would be
i would be derelict in my duty if i
didn't point out here
that the people in this country
the right wingers in this country
that are
digging digging on biting
are you al-qaeda here the american
taliban
because frankly we have a way bigger
risk of domestic right-wing
religious fundamentalist terrorists in
this country than we do anywhere else in
the world
a real present danger here in this
country from religious
cult-like
fundamentalist
domestic terrorist
yalkaida
american taliban
and there's a hundred names for them
but these q anon maga
trump hump and evangelicals
are not only spreading around two
viruses the delta variant and stupidity
the stupidity virus
but it seems to me it seems to me from
january 6 and on to this point they're
still trying to wipe their ass with the
constitution
we have the legislator down in georgia
oh boy they're just going to take over
the election board in fulton county
[ __ ] fulton county and [ __ ] what they
want [ __ ] democracy who wants democracy
we want
we want the cult
the trump-a-mania cult
people going to school boards and
threatening
threatening school boards about masked
mandates to keep children safe
what the [ __ ]
proud boys
getting physically violent
with counter protesters for their
anti-backs mandate
protest or whatever the [ __ ] it was
their cult meeting their nazi rally
bunch of [ __ ] proud boys what what
the [ __ ] where'd they come up with that
name
they know they know what that sounds
like right
but we have a problem with the american
taliban the al-qaeda here in this
country
that we should be dealing with
i think that is the more clear and
present danger here
and i think maybe maybe just maybe our
security apparatus should concentrate on
that
not concentrating on a country that we
couldn't convince people to be in a
democracy for 20 years it took us and
the taliban took it back in two weeks
because they never lost it folks they
never lost it
they never lost grip on that country
they let us think they did because
americans aren't [ __ ] paying
attention
[ __ ] half of america couldn't point out
afghanistan on a map
if it was spelled out to him
we can't even get people to realize that
if you are unvaccinated and you're
coughing and sneezing on people with a
deadly pathogen it'll get them sick
we can't even convince them of simple
things like that
so yeah
i think most americans
are behind joe biden when it comes to
the afghanistan war and i think trump
really [ __ ] on himself
when he's basically blaming the
afghanistan exit on on biden when it was
his deal that was made
because in the end
the american people are going to give
joe biden credit for leaving everybody
gives richard nixon lee credit for
leaving vietnam
joe biden's gonna get credit for it no
one else
just like he's gonna take the blame for
people clinging on the side of a plane
which again
when used talk about the entire 20 years
almost 20 years that we were in
afghanistan
that is not the worst debacle that we
have had
in our 20 years in afghanistan
and how many more [ __ ] american lives
and this is what americans are thinking
how many more american lives are we
going to sacrifice
for that country not to come to grips
that they need to be a democracy because
we want them to be
we want them to be something and they
better be it and that really american of
us
to force someone
to be something that they don't want to
be
get the [ __ ] out of here
americans are going to give credit for
joe biden getting out of afghanistan
because he's going to take the blame for
the debacle of the exit
so he's gonna get the credit
so there you go
there's the stance on afghanistan and
you better write it down and you better
record this
because as soon as they get the exit of
these people in afghanistan that they
want out the americans the allied
personnel
and the afghanis that helped us the 20
years while we were there when they
helped those people and get those people
exited
and to safety
not a goddamn person is going to talk
about afghanistan not a [ __ ] not
one
not one we won't give two more [ __ ]
about afghanistan than we have the last
20 years folks
that's one reason why this country is
sick of it
they don't know [ __ ] about it
they don't want to know [ __ ] about it
we're americans baby
cheeseburgers
football games
professional wrestling
that's what we want
forget about policy forget about war
forget about foreign policy
and stuff isn't that stuff isn't sexy
americans won't remember just like they
don't remember the kurds
they don't remember
and they won't
afghanistan
what afghanistan what
what about afghanistan didn't joe bias
getting out of get us out of that war
i thought we got out of that war
oh oh that's what the story is about
getting out of the war oh okay well
that's a good thing
that's america for you baby
apple pie
guns god country
that's where we're at thank you for
joining me today
to talk about afghanistan probably for
one of the last times on this podcast i
would imagine
i don't see that the american people are
going to even pay attention even if i
would talk about afghanistan
because they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't
and they won't
other than joe biden got us out
unfortunately that's how it is
[ __ ] we don't even care about good
policy here
it's more about the trumpet mania about
the show
about giving the fans what they want
getting on fox news and telling them
what they want to hear
cracking that beer over your face stone
cold steve austin making a show of it
making a mockery of american politics
that's what you're supposed to do
so thank you for joining me here on the
podcast and next week join me again
wednesday three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern i'm sure there's going
to be a whole host of new things to talk
about next week
just like we had the war
exiting in afghanistan we've got to talk
about this week i'm sure there's going
to be plenty of good news plenty of bad
news to talk about next week so join me
next week wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern right here
on youtube on twitter or on twitch
that's where you can watch us you can
also download the podcast after i get it
done with the live show i post it up
to apple to spotify and you can go
download it and listen to it there until
next time
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them